une partie très importante de notre
législation sur la liberté d'expression
est en quelque sorte
hanté par justement cette période de
l'entre-deux-guerres ou en fait tu
n'existais pas de restriction de la
liberté d'expression de ce qu'on appelle
en tout cas les discours de haine il
existe évidemment des limitations de la
liberté d'expression pour préserver les
bonnes moeurs ou là ou éventuellement la
morale publique mais il n'existait pas
effectivement d'incrimination pour
l'incitation à la haine raciale pour les
injures ça ce sont des choses qui sont
arrivées largement après la seconde
guerre mondiale toute cette législation
est inspiré par le fait qu'en réalité
cette liberté d'expression excessive qui
avaient libre cours en tout cas dans les
sociétés européennes pas seulement en
france mais aussi en allemagne en
autriche dans l'entre-deux-guerres a
contribué largement à été en quelque
sorte cause en tout cas adjuvant de
l'extermination et des génocides qui ont
eu lieu par la suite et donc aussi une
raison pour laquelle la la plupart des
sociétés européennes en fait la totalité
des sociétés européennes se sont dotés
de législations à partir des années 60
70 contre ce qu'on appelle les discours
de haine et c'est justement en fait sur
ses lois que s'inscrivent la plupart des
polémiques récentes autour de la satire
pourquoi parce que comme on l'a dit tout
à l'heure à la satire presque par sa
fonction à vocation à être agressive y
compris de la loi alors quand la loi
consiste à protéger la morale et le chef
de l'état la satire va être presque
naturellement portés dialectiquement
presque à s'attaquer à ces institutions
là lorsque la loi protège justement par
référence en tout cas aux crimes passés
des groupes d'individus définis par leur
race leur ethnie leur religion la
question c'est est-ce que la satire ne
va pas presque par fonction est ramenée
à s'attaquer à ces lois et à ces groupes
et c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles en fait l'exercice de la
satire est si difficile aujourd'hui
[Musique]